find the opposite of 2x squared minus 7x
plus 13 so in this context when they're
talking about opposite they're really
just talking about the negative of the
expression so if I told you find the
opposite of one in this context I'd say
well you know that would be the negative
of it it would be negative one if I said
find the opposite of 17 it would be the
negative of that it would be negative 17
if I told you find the opposite of
negative 3 well it would be the negative
of that so it would be positive 3 they
are opposites of each other so to go
from one number to its opposite you just
multiply by negative 1 multiply by
negative 1 multiply by negative 1 so to
find the opposite of this polynomial we
just have to do the same thing we have
to multiply the polynomial by negative 1
so let's do that it's going to be
negative 1 times this entire expression
2x squared minus 7x plus 13 and now
remember we're multiplying the entire
expression times negative 1 so we have
to distribute the negative 1 so this is
going to be negative 1 times 2x squared
negative 1 times 2x squared plus
negative 1 times negative 7x so it's
going to be negative it's going to be
the sum of negative 1 times each of the
terms so plus negative 1 times negative
7x plus negative 1 times positive 13
plus negative 1 times positive 13 and so
what does this give us this negative 1
times 2x squared is negative 2x squared
negative 1 times negative 7 is positive
7 so this gives us plus 7x and then
negative 1 times 13 is negative 13 so
minus 13 and we are done negative 2x
squared plus 7x minus 13